Okay, it's been a couple of weeks.
Let's do some book recommendations backstory
on this segment.
I used to do these weekly, the segments did
terribly on YouTube.
We stopped doing them, but due to popular
demand, people said, David, please bring back
the book recommendation, so I'm doing this
like every two to three weeks.
I will will remind you, and this is what hopefully
will make this a worthwhile to continue doing.
If you go to David pakman.com/recommendations
you will find all of these recommendations
and others with Amazon links where if you
buy them through the links at David pakman.com/recommendations
we get a slice like Andrew Yang likes to say,
a slice of an Amazon transaction.
We get a slice of your Amazon transaction.
If you use the links at David pakman.com/recommendations
to buy these books.
I've got two nonfiction books here and two
fiction books.
Let's get right into it.
First one, nonfiction life 3.0 by max Tegmark.
This is a great book about artificial intelligence.
I believe that it was build Gates who had
recommended this one, at least put it on my
radar.
Very, very good because it is not hyperbolic.
This book life 3.0 we'll take all of the different
fears and hypotheses around the development
of artificial intelligence and it will sort
of like simmer down and speak in much more
measured ways about the risks and the possibilities
of artificial intelligence.
I highly recommend it.
It has some parts in it that you can sort
of skip depending on your knowledge of technology.
I just read the entire thing.
Um, but definitely don't miss this one.
Life 3.0 by max Tegmark second nonfiction
book today.
This one I read, uh, about a year ago.
This is called traffic by Tom Vanderbilt.
This is a book about traffic on the roads
and it will explain to you there.
So traffic is interesting because the, the,
the concept of traffic is interesting because
there are like mathematical elements to understanding
why is it that we're going so slowly if there
is no crash, like what, what's causing this
slow down?
I don't understand that.
What is the most efficient means of merging
when there is emerge?
There are a lot of, a lot of mathematical
considerations around traffic, but there's
also a lot of sociology and culture around
how highway systems are designed in different
countries.
Um, there are probably other examples that
I'm forgetting here.
This book, uh, discusses a lot of that traffic,
why we drive the way we do and what it says
about us by Tom Vanderbilt.
Get it, enjoy it.
If you don't drive, you will certainly get
pleasure out of, uh, taking public transit
after reading this book.
For sure.
Let's now do two fiction recommendations.
All right.
Now this one I was very hesitant to, so I,
I in general, I'm kind of hesitant often to
jump into authors that do like the massive
bestsellers that sometimes feel sort of like
there for the lowest common denominator.
And I don't say that at any kind of, I dunno,
pejorative way, but like I've never read a
Stephen King book up until a few months ago.
I just kind of resisted the craze around it.
Whatever this book is really worth reading.
It's a big one.
It is 21, a New York 2140 by Kim Stanley Robinson.
I've read nothing else by Kim Stanley Robinson
in my life.
This was thoroughly enjoyable without passing
any judgment of any kind on any other work
by Robinson.
This is a great book because it combines great
readability, interesting characters with the
issue of climate change, climate, destabilization
of rising sea wa a sea level.
And a lot of the stuff that we're dealing
with today, I don't know that I need to say
much more about it, but if you're into Saifai,
if you're into climate change, dystopian sort
of stuff, this is a great book.
It is about 600 pages.
It goes quickly.
It really is a quick read, as quick as 600
pages can be.
And lastly, this was recommended to me by,
um, a writer, Elliott pepper, who I will sometimes
trade recommendations with and whose books
I recommended before.
It is called ABA.
God row Corp or avocado corporation is what
it stands for.
Avogadro's corporation in the book.
This is by William Hertling.
This is a place holder for a sort of massive
multinational could be Google, like could
be Apple, like you know that type of company
and it is, let's see, how much do I want to
say about it?
Let's just say that it takes, you know how
Gmail now has this feature where it has predictive
text.
If you haven't turned on as you're writing,
it will consider what it is likely you are
going to write and let you auto fill.
It will say, Oh, you're probably, if you start
saying, um, let's figure out tomorrow whether
we can increase, it might add in the prices
if it knows that you're often talking about
increasing or decreasing prices or whatever.
The book jumps off from the idea of a more
advanced version of that Gmail feature that
doesn't do predictive text on the basis of
what it thinks you are likely to want to say.
But it actually can restructure emails on
the basis of who the recipient is to make
them more influential when the recipient gets
that email.
So I might write a sales email and the function
might say, Oh, based on who it's going to,
here's how that email could be rewritten to
make it more likely that you're going to make
a sale.
That's the idea and it expands from there
into the problems that come from that.
Really, really good.
It's actually kind of good to pair this as
a fiction book.
Oh, with life 3.0 by max Tegmark so check
these out, all of these and many more recommendations
available at David pakman.com/recommendations
any links you use on that page to buy these
or other books, we will get a slice of those
Amazon purchases, which is a really, really
great thing and I appreciate everybody who
is already doing that.